peut penser à 10000 un système qui
probablement même viendront mais des
systèmes d' alerte pour la coupe
population comment on fait par exemple
il ya des français qui ont développé ce
type d'application comment on fait pour
alerter en guadeloupe en martinique et
bien toute l'épopée toute la population
de l'ouragan qui arrive dans une
demi-heure ou d'ingénieurs et bien la 5g
cette rapidité de réseau permet
également de répondre à ce type de
d'application je rappelle juste que ces
cas une quasi temps réel
le débit est multiplié par dix et le
délai de transmission des données est
divisé par dix donc effectivement sur
les aspects purement techniques on
parlera de les impacts sociétaux
évidemment tout à l'heure et bien pu
remonter cnic et applicatifs
il me semble que effectivement il ya des
usages qui sont très intéressants et je
crois qu'il faut raisonner je
terminerais là sur ce point sur ce point
il faut raisonner aussi au niveau bien
sûr internationale pourquoi on développe
la 5g en france ou en europe parce que
les chinois développe la singer les
américains développeurs que la singer et
qu'on ne peut pas imaginer je dirais ne
pas aller vers ces technologies et bien
sinon on a une perte de compétitivité
très forte de les entreprises
[Musique]